dieser regelverstoß kostet
[Musik]
allerdings darf ich euch heute hier
dennoch herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einer neuen episode luca also ich
reagiere auf to how to handle unsere
lieblings netflix serie am ende der
letzten episode hat ja harry francesca
geküsst von daher bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt wie dies in anderen sagen und
wie viel geld die von 100.000 euro jetzt
verloren haben
[Musik]
mein herz rast
wenn herz rast
ja ihr habt gerade eine menge geld
glaube ich für ein sestak an ihren mund
nicht halten die wird haley sagen dass
wir uns geküsst haben hören wissen dass
alle also muss ich es den jungs gleich
sagen und dann wirklich nicht wie der
letzte versteht also die packen direkt
aus den ich aber auch richtig so die
sollten ja alle offen und transparent
miteinander umgehen
[Musik]
land
hätte ich jetzt doch nicht gedacht dass
sie das so schnell aus packe ich dachte
es wird bis jetzt irgendwie mit einem
spannungsbogen oder so einem einsturz
endlich ist es trotz handicap jetzt
glaube ich keinen großen spannungsbogen
verraten
und jetzt werden mich alle hassen
wahrscheinlich ich will trotzdem wissen
wie viel geld den jetzt verloren
gegangen ist und dem scheint das alles
egal zu sein das ist uns einfach tun
[Musik]
mehr
maggetti möchte ich weiß nicht eine
verwirrte ist also ich kann da auch
gerne helfen ich wohne in köln falls ihr
habt uns also geld gekostet
wir wissen nicht wie viel das könnte nur
einen dollar seien aber mich würde
wirklich interessieren wieviel uns ihr
kurs gekostet hat ich würde sagen wir
stimmen jetzt mal ab schreibt mir
einfach mal jetzt wirklich im real tor
kläglich jetzt unten in die kommentare
was ihr denkt wie teuer das für die war
ich sage
ich sag 5000 dollar nein das viel zu
viel
ich sag 1000 es schwierig sagt 1000 doch
ich doch tausenden sie sich jeden tag
ist das dann 100 dollar am tag
einen monat muss man halt auch bedenken
hatte lange zeit nicht ex nicht exotisch
aber war sie nicht auch die die natur
hat sie auch nicht weiß was da drauf
stehen also dass die mit so viel check
das wird glaube ich na hauptsache ich
bin nicht die böse ist die böse ihr seid
ja das hat sich ja gelohnt moment
francesca will nicht die böse sein
natürlich du hast auch mit harry
rumgeknutscht wer soll denn der böse
sein
also francesca ich würde das auch auf
mich nicht ich habe es verbockt hat mir
bitte erst mal zu was kommt wir haben
uns unterhalten würden vierte eins zum
anderen
wir haben uns geküsst freue ich mich
jetzt so ich habe davon der gar nicht
aber ich bin gespannt wie die anderen
reagieren
der clou statt mit dem heißesten mädchen
der welt internet flick serie rom und
sich verschluckt mich an und wasser
schluckt ich war wehrlos
[Musik]
letztes wichtiges modul story was ich
habe im affekt gehandelt und den jungs
gesagt von chester hätte mich geküsst ja
und das ist falsch
und jetzt steht er francesca als die
böse da die natürlich klar jetzt outen
sich gewehrt hat gegen den kuss aber er
kam voll auf sie zu beherrschen ist
nicola vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht
viel wissen noch immer nicht wie teuer
das alles ist
so vana kannst uns das nicht mehr sagen
du warst dumm und hat mist gebaut
aber sie hat dich geküsst es kann mir
verzeihen ganz blöde nummer jetzt für
harry auf der einen seite hat er von
chef ganz schlechtes licht gerückt und
auf der anderen seite seinen homies
nicht die wahrheit erzählt hast noch
viel zu lernen und mit unserer hilfe
wird das schon und die drei weisen
diesen jesus haben die auch nur damit
rein geholt damit die sonne running der
kampf so der sieht also ich meine ich
kann das nicht beurteilen ich bin ein
typ und heterosexueller also ich stehe
auf frauen ich kann es nicht sagen wer
von den jüngster der ices ist aber ich
würde schon sagen dass jesus mit abstand
der am schlechtesten ausgeht ist
übrigens sind alle meine kommentare mal
wieder bitte nicht persönlich
beleidigend oder attackieren zu
verstehen ich kenne keine von diesen
personen persönlich aber francesca
vielleicht lass mich in ruhe hla meine
liebste reiten die auf derselben welle
mit dir ja
jesus mit dir will keiner flirten
dieses ding da bittet rommel alle gäste
in panama zusammenhänge aber eine
wichtige ankündigung zu machen
ich glaube jetzt erfahren wir mal so
langsam wie teuer dieser kurs war ich
habe neuigkeiten für es gab einen
regelverstoß macht diana mädels wissen
nicht bescheid
okay das jetzt wird's richtig
interessant wer was du solltest du hier
schon jeder
jetzt weißt du schon mehrmals und
francesca barcamps sind die hält
wenn sie das gros
harry
ist dein ernst
der tut jetzt sollst als wahl allerdings
oder b
die haben doch gleich selbst streit aber
wenn du ihn zum schlichten boss
francesco also wir haben geknutscht hat
schon krasse augen
in ceska
die nicht beobachten würden haben
geschnitzt dieser regelverstoß kostet
3000 gerade auf den tisch zu hauen
o
ich bete für euch heilige mutter gott
ist dass sie nicht von dieser aufnahme
hier von carl sack doch einfach schon
alles
es ist eine woche dubai das war ein
toller kurs wird 3
das kriegt man den amsterdam drei tagen
die sache ist werden auch in der letzten
folge rausgefunden dass nicht jeder kopf
von denen 100.000 euro bekommt sondern
alle zusammen und die teilen sich dass
das heißt jeder bekommt 10.000 euro das
heißt jeder muss jetzt quasi 300 euro
nicht bekommt
wegen dem kurs falls die matte frage
habt ihr wendet euch einfach an mich
oder francesca fliegen wird den rest
kannst du wieder zu denken oder raus
jetzt geht's los ist so unglaublich
wirklich könnte das stimmt ob wir
blicken wir hier für drahtlose am start
unfassbar wir haben eine lampe aus buch
obwohl diese folge gar keine rede anteil
hatte dafür hat er harry harun farocki
schreier umso mehr du hast nicht
gewartet bei der das geld egal wie kann
er die ganze zeit blass dass ich war es
pro jahr seit wurden kameras umgeben
es steht ja nicht wort gegen wort so
steht ein wort gegen dich und 70.000
kameras bohr und ich wünsche mir vor
allem an deiner stelle nicht mit
francesca verhauen weil die geist der
franziska wenn du möchtest man da nicht
genau was gerade passiert
ich glaube ich habe nur wie ich ja schon
gesagt habe vor einigen minuten
irgendwie aber ich habe ziemlich viel in
der folge dass mich am meisten stört ist
nicht dass er nicht zugibt dass er
angefangen hat das ein nicht mehr
schuldig tja francesca ich bin auf
deiner seite
ich werde auch immer auf deiner seite
sein und auch wenn du dann mal hier ich
glaube harry gar nichts wir haben eine
kleine krise
krisensituation
wie ich schon gesagt habe harry hat sich
einerseits bei francesca ein bisschen
reingehauen dadurch dass sie sie jetzt
in die fahrrad laufen lassen und auch
bei seinen hobbys die halt angelogen hat
und jetzt sind alle und ich glaube auch
die meisten zuschauer gegen harry
und der harry
beweg dich mal weg
komm mal rein es gab da
dass man jetzt mit kühler und kehlen im
vierer wg einfach aber alles zu seiner
zeit
deshalb habe ich das heute wieder zu
beenden weil er lieben freude wenn euch
meine reaktion hier mal wieder auf to
how to handle lkw finger weg also diesem
fx serie gefallen hat dann lasst
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier das schaffen wir 60.000 leid
dass er geisteskrank und wird mit zeigen
ihr feiert das und ihr habt doch noch
bock auf den sechsten teil wie ich
darauf reagieren
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto und wenn ihr hier oben auf
den zwei die darauf könnt ihr kostenlos
main kanal abonnieren und verpasst keine
videos mehr denn die dann schon abonnent
seit klickt auch gerne auf die glocke
denn dadurch bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und hier ist ein video
verlinkt das leben auf meinem 2 kanal
online gegangen ist in diesem video habe
ich mal wieder eine das video endet
venture dichtgemacht und verändert das
video sobald ich noch nie schreibt das
klingt das kann